it's like that it's like that dramatic
stuff oh the camera go
yeah
[Music]
yeah
welcome back everybody to another great
episode of careful boys we have with us
Christian Farina okay we also have Ed
park over there by the way hey thanks
for having me and Jason the new Harry
yeah Jason so we got a hot seat episode
right now we're gonna go ahead and ask
Christian some hot questions uh the way
that it works is we like to ask
increasingly hot questions as we go
along but traditionally we start with
Bart who'll ask you the coldest possible
thing you've ever heard in your life
okay right now uh-huh you're not gonna
say [ __ ] anymore
your mouth is now your butthole
and
you have diarrhea what sound does it
make go
okay
there couldn't have been a wrong answer
to that that's great that's very nice
that's a nice diarrhea son great
icebreakers do I gotta do that the rest
of them yeah speak in Diary of form no
so you you didn't grow up in La I didn't
I grew up in Wisconsin yeah what part
what part uh
grew up in Milwaukee and then moved
about like an hour out in like Waukesha
area so when you came out here did your
parents come with you or were you just
like I'm gonna make it in LA yeah it was
one of those situations
um so actually my parents ended up
getting a divorce when I was a senior in
high school uh perfect timing it was
like an affair like crazy [ __ ] going on
and so they were dealing with that whole
situation I had previously been a dancer
was doing that going to high school and
stuff
um I didn't really have a college plan
yet
um but since my parents were doing all
that there's a lot of stuff that
happened financially
um I didn't have plans for school and I
had to like make the decision and I was
like if there's one thing I love and
know I can do in life it's dance so I
literally packed up two suitcases flew
that I lay and just started figuring it
out how old were you I was 18.
at like when you're on the year like I
yeah you just turn your light I was 18 I
finished out high school they were
having like the family situations and
stuff and I was like either I can stay
here in Wisconsin which I didn't really
want to be
um and kind of just like have a little
pity party go to Community College or
something or I was like I can go do
something with my life so I moved out
here
um yeah and started figuring it out so
when you got here what was that like did
you know people did you know did you
have jobs laid out for you like what was
it you were just like at LAX like here I
am
kind of actually so I didn't know people
out here
um I had this girl I saw she like posted
on Facebook I kind of knew her from like
competing with dance stuff she used to
live in Chicago but she had lived in La
I saw she was looking for a roommate I
was like hey can I move in there's a two
bedroom there's a couple and then I took
the other room shot I literally got
dropped off they picked me up moved into
this apartment I slept on an air
mattress for two and a half years wow uh
yeah I had no jobs planned um was she
like yo how are you gonna pay rent
it was like I obviously didn't prep for
all this family stuff to happen so I
wasn't like making money or anything I
ended up like using the connections I
worked for a dance competition I first
moved out here
um I made up my own job I was like I
will film and edit for you this was
before like social media was getting big
and stuff and I didn't want to do a
regular job so I was like hey I'll come
I'll film the dance stuff I'll make like
reels so I taught myself how to edit and
all that so that's how I would make
money because I'd travel on the weekends
and do that one of the first people I
met when I moved out here the girl's
boyfriend
um was an assistant to Philip Shabib oh
the dancer yeah and I like somehow
Philip is like a really big dancer super
talented I had no clue who he was but he
was like hey we need an extra person on
set to film a little video you down to
help so I went and helped and I met one
of the best people I probably could in
the dance industry yeah absolutely and
that's like how I met you guys too like
somehow it just worked out where I found
the right network of people right away
um and these people were a lot older
than me like clearly like 30 years older
thank you
it kind of like mentored me and stuff
you got pretty lucky but at the same
time you had to take that that leap of
faith you had to do the courageous thing
yeah to come here in the lucky situation
right and that's what people don't know
is like a lot of the times they'll just
be like they'll play it off as oh that's
some girl that just got lucky but then
you still had it I was like I was on air
mattress for two and a half yeah you
have to hustle I have a picture of my
room like it literally was I actually
stacked to it air mattresses that's
luxury
Comfort hacks no but seriously I had
like nothing I just figured it out
um the biggest thing I was like okay I
know I love people and I love meeting
them I'm just gonna meet everyone I can
and try to figure it out there wasn't
really a plan B I feel like situations
like that in life help you get there
when there's not really another option
um yeah what's the scariest
a situation or just like a uh like added
on together
when you were here like as a
circumstance where you like [ __ ] uh
there's this time where rent was due but
this paycheck couldn't come in I don't
know if I had to go back home or like
what was a serious compounding
circumstance that you experienced there
was one circumstance I mean definitely
like those first couple of years was
tough because I wasn't booking anything
also when it comes to dance I was
trained in something completely
different than what is typically booked
out here out here it's more like
commercial stuff you got hip hop I never
I never really trained in hip-hop stuff
I also wasn't like the
sexy girl heels video type what kind of
dance were you doing like tap dancing
like more traditional stuff like
contemporary type of stuff
um let's continue the Last Dance
[Laughter]
girl China
sing in the rain it's like that it's
like that dramatic stuff oh the camera
go
[Music]
I was a little bit cooler than that but
then I met these guys and they were
doing like cool hip-hop [ __ ] and I was
like hey let me learn that and that's
actually how I booked the first national
commercial
yes but I don't know circumstance I'm
trying to think of this if there's like
you hit rock bottom ever when the [ __ ]
was hitting the fan the hardest yeah
yeah I mean I think that was like that I
think like the second month of me living
out here it kind of was like what the
[ __ ] is happening because
my family life was insane back home and
I kind of just wanted to escape from
that I also moved out here like in
August I didn't know people leave
um during the holiday months oh so all
my roommates had left is that no one's
really like from here from I yeah I
didn't know the city yet I didn't have a
lot of money I didn't have a car
um thank God I had an apartment but when
everyone left to like go home to their
families and stuff it was like November
December January I basically stayed in
my apartment for like two months
straight I barely left and I feel like
how we were talking about when you're
alone yeah like I swear I was kind of
like mentally going insane a little bit
because like there's so many unstable
parts of my life and I was there alone
it kind of like it was the culture shock
like what's happening quarantine before
quarantine yeah basically but did you
have friends like come out to visit you
during that time no because I've been in
that situation too my first year moving
here same thing everybody went home for
the holidays and I wasn't gonna go home
I stayed here and I did the Harry Potter
marathon first and then luckily I had a
friend who didn't want to to be with
their family for the holidays so we just
chilled down my life yeah I feel like
you slowly just meet people I mean it's
a mixing pot of people so it helped over
time like I started building my
foundation and family out here but I
feel like initially that yeah it's just
tough you know
we do create a second family out in L.A
a lot like there's like always like well
I mean like I wish you I knew you guys
back then well you you've been to one of
our friendsgivings and [ __ ] but we
always try to create something because
half of the team was out of state yeah
and and it's the same reason because
there's so many people here for
entertainment like we're actually local
like we born and raised here in this
area and and I always forget how many
people come here for work right and then
they they're at their actual home is
like far away yeah yeah you know what's
crazy is like did I meet you within that
time that you were
uh you met I had probably been out in La
for maybe a year so I was actually still
struggling a good amount when you guys
met me I was pretty good at putting a
front on it but I feel like that's why I
attached so much to your group and like
looked up to you guys I think it's so
weird because she didn't show I didn't
shame you but I feel like that's also
part of it too that got me through is
like I wasn't gonna settle and like live
in that state like I was like trying to
like you know surround myself with
people that I want to be like and I am
not let that consume me you know yeah
but it was during that time that's crazy
I had no idea yeah because she really
like when we met her we were like yo
she's so cool because she's her sense of
humor is super open and she's just so
goofy and I would have never thought
that was like a hard time
yeah who who's your role model in your
family is there someone in your family
that like did well and you're like and
that kind of was your inspiration to
crush it
um
or is there everyone like a Wisconsin
loser no no I
I know my family had issues
really like each member of my family is
great there's just like some stuff that
happened I really look up to my dad
because he was a lieutenant
um and in the military or no uh police
officer he's a lieutenant he kind of was
like the hero in that sense and he um he
retired early and he was the one he
drive me an hour and a half to Studio to
dance every day when I was in school so
like I owed that to him uh he was very
supportive with that but I feel like
right now if there's a superhero in my
family it's probably my sister
um my sister kind of did the same thing
there's a lot going on at home so she
ended up moving to Atlanta she got
pregnant pretty early
um she has two kids now
um and she got pregnant before she got
married she like went through a tough
time with that
um her son is autistic her first kid she
had and she was young so just seeing her
like raise him and like be strong and
kind of like take care of everything in
that sense she also was the person that
like I kind of escaped and ran out here
and chased my dreams but she stayed home
during all of that and kind of mediated
everything so she's pretty great is she
your older sister yeah she's my older
sister she's probably like four years
older than me yeah yeah damn is this hot
Cedar tissue scene
small mild tissue seat
damn so what um how long you been in La
for I've been here almost six years now
so during that I guess climb right like
you're obviously
achieving a lot of things that you came
out here to do
do you ever kind of feel like oh [ __ ]
I'm doing what I wanted or like you know
do you ever take a moment to like look
at that or like yeah I
I fall for like
that I've done and the opportunities
that I've done because it did take a
while to start booking and stuff but
once I did like there have been so many
things I've always dreamed about that
I've just like checked off the list and
when you're in that moment it's kind of
like if you guys know how it is but it
feels a little bit surreal like this is
happening but like just taking a step
back and be like this is what I wanted
and I worked for this and now I'm
getting what I deserve I also think
it does get hard too because
when you start booking you're in that
mindset you kind of like keep striving
for more which I think is great but also
like along the way just appreciating
what you've done but I've accomplished a
ton and you know I'm grateful for that
what was it what was it like uh seeing
yourself on TV for the first time yeah
that was crazy it was so cool it was big
[ __ ] you to everyone at home
[Laughter]
yeah I was just gonna ask what your
friends back home think
but no it was so like doing TV stuff
when I was on World of Dance that was
the first TV show did I actually
um my dad for a minute like he supported
dance but I feel like he fully you know
I was having a tough time out here and
you know wasn't really booking a lot of
stuff yet and I don't think he really
saw dance as a career but um he ended up
flying out and watching a live taping
and like you know he's like in the crowd
like sitting next to JLo and he's like
okay if you kind of started to see what
I was doing so I think that was a really
cool moment for me in my career that's
cool through all your accomplishments
um do you deal with imposter syndrome
what do you mean by that sorry if I feel
them uh imposter syndrome is where
um you're just kind of like what the
[ __ ] am I doing like I don't deserve
this like how am I in this position with
all of this greatness or do you feel
you're in the right I'm I'm in the right
spot because I feel like
when you
you work your ass
the goal before you're there and then
you achieve it is different than like
things just happening
um you know it's not like everything was
great and like I had a rich family and I
came out here and I'm dancing and like
wow I got all these jobs and now these
connections like it really did take a
lot of work and a lot of time to make
things happen so I don't think I've
really had much of that I have had like
sometimes like
like what the [ __ ] am I doing you know
what I mean because I I feel like doing
so many different things like social
media and then stuff but I never think
it's in a negative sense so then
referring back to your [ __ ] you to
Wisconsin
did you have did you have a lot of
people discourage you from coming out to
LA and saying this is a crazy idea this
is dumb like yeah I I didn't really
listen to it
people
that come from other places especially a
place from Wisconsin they they see what
they're around you know Wisconsin is
very much a place where you know you
grow up with your family you go to
school go to college you get married to
your high school sweetheart you have
kids Three Doors Down from your parents
like everyone kind of stays there so I
definitely think people were a little
bit like what is she doing
um but I didn't listen to any of that
because you know at the end of the day
it's my life I'm gonna chase what I want
and make the Wisconsin loser I mean
there's other people that did stuff but
I think just like majority that just
wasn't for me not the lifestyle I wanted
when you got into social media and then
you started your Tick Tock and then that
blew up did you ever feel the pressure
of having to like keep doing content and
constantly having to make stuff for that
yeah I feel like burnout is definitely a
thing you guys know how it is even
though you're crushing it you know uh
burnout is a huge thing
I don't know I think so we're being
crushed
um
for a moment and got tired
yeah we're crumbling it not crushing it
I feel like constantly just being on
camera and creating content I mean you
know how it is like always being on
camera and stuff I think I learned that
a lot with the injury when I fell off
the roof and I had dance taken away from
me and I didn't really feel like
creating because I wasn't like doing
much
um I feel like you need that break
sometimes like I can't always be on
camera like sometimes I just want to
live a little bit so I feel like there's
a balance you know treating it almost as
work and then having my down time
because you can't burn yourself out
that's can you rewind a little bit you
fell off a roof oh
um I was in Miami at an Airbnb and
there's a rooftop like a little ladder
to get to the rooftop I'd go up there
and like look at the city every night
um there was one night I was coming down
the ladder and my hand slipped and I
fell 15 feet backwards on the concrete
um and I broke six Bones on my arm just
okay my shoulders sprained my back it
was Christmas Eve I was in the hospital
um so it was about like a year of
recovery so during that year I was that
I mean talk about another hard time like
that for me because you know me I was
like go go I was constantly doing things
like I love that
um I love working hard I love dancing I
love making things happen for it all to
be stripped away I was kind of like what
is going on you know a little bit of
like what's left and having to like
figure out how to deal with that at and
appreciate other things in my life
besides like being successful and
working hard and dancing stuff but yeah
I fell for roof yeah what was the uh
what was the thing that got you out of
that like because I know how that's like
to be injured and you can't dance and
you're just watching everything move
past you as you're just chilling what
got you to keep going after you got
better
um
it was actually really tough and I feel
like I'm still kind of in that phase
um even though you're 100 healed yeah no
think it's um more the mental aspect of
it because when you have everything
shipped away and you see these people
succeeding and doing stuff I didn't do
anything for a year and I'm just I am
that type of person like you know I want
to do things I want I have big goals and
things I want to achieve in my life so
for that to be paused it definitely was
really tough I also got a little bit
comfortable and then just the big leap
it feels like okay let's get back into
this let's do all this extra work to get
back all like these tricks and stuff and
get my body back to that
um it definitely was like a hard
transition I feel like I'm still kind of
going through that but definitely on the
up of it to like get back to like
constantly doing things because we don't
do anything and get comfortable it's
hard to get back into it at least for me
personally yeah
it's almost like a domino effect like
you got to do one and it's snowballs
right but then if you just stop
then like to get that it's like an old
car you gotta remember remember best
friend in life like when you have that
momentum and it's going good yeah like
to build it back up it takes time and
yeah also for Kristen like she's in my
opinion like she's doing when she was
like really really doing everything
that's way more than an average dancer
would do anyway what do you mean by that
can you paint a picture of like what
dancers do because I I think dancers
dance a lot so there's some dancers that
are more involved in like auditioning
and just doing like hard work and then
there's other dancers who are proactive
about going out and just collaborating
with everyone that could possibly
partner with them and then there's
others that are doing social media and
more focused on that she was just all of
the above yeah and all the time and a
very like oh yeah before you uh like if
I had something to offer I'm like hey
Christian there's this job I should be
like yeah let's do it let's [ __ ] do
it and like it's not one of those people
that goes tell me the rates and tell me
what I have to do like she's like all
right what day go get her like like I'm
down that's bad I used to hit her up all
the time because I'm like you I got the
perfect person for you because you know
sometimes a lot of people don't know
what they want when they need a dancer
and it's like Kristen's perfect then
because she's training in all styles
like I was creating I was collaborating
like
it was like a superhero type thing like
I'm really proud of that way I used to
live and I'm getting back into it though
you know what I mean I also feel like
that's kind of just like an innate
quality in myself so do you ever feel
like you're never stretched too thin oh
no I definitely
get stretched thin sometimes but
um yeah just learning when to step back
I think that comes with age too because
also when you knew me you know I was
like 19 20 that kind of age like the
older I get like there's definitely
priorities you have to take care of
yourself but I feel like that's a great
mentality to have in life to just like
go after what you want and do cool
things a lot of people read lineup up
until their 50s and and then they die
like redlining I think that personality
like it's it's like so fun that you
don't know your limits so everything is
yes yes let's go let's go
and then you don't really know like
you're you need a little rest or mental
break sure yeah because it is fun like
everything is like I remember when we
were redlining it was three hours of
sleep at night and then but then
everything was just so exciting that you
and also it feels bad to say no because
your friends are up for it or like the
money's so damn good and you never had a
taste of that before
and I do miss it I miss redlining yeah
yeah but what does redlining mean or
like pushing yourself to uh beyond your
limits every day and you think you could
do more and more that's amazing every
single hour of your day and your week
and your month to the point where you
like like let's say if my mom wanted to
have dinner with me and we live in the
same city I'm like you need to tell me
four weeks in advance it's impossible
like there's no way I can what do you
mean you want to have dinner like this
Saturday you might be hopping from one
gig to another or doing two gig
simultaneously at the same time but you
know I complain less during that time I
felt you know much I probably had no
time to complain I also got you to where
you are though and I feel like there's a
healthy there's a balance yeah yeah and
that's what I learned from the end it
was two extremes like I was doing that
extreme thing that we're just talking
about like go go go and then to complete
nothing for a year so now I I appreciate
that experience and why that happened
because it taught me that I do need I
need to take care of my body and slow
down and kind of can balance both of
those things yeah do you only climb
ladders with gloves on now just to make
sure you stick better
are you afraid by the way after that
no I mean I still went to Mexico yeah
right she's still doing giant Ash water
slides yeah yeah that's good yo Mexico
theme parks are on another level dude
Park on water parks it's crazier though
things are just crazier yeah I feel like
there's no rules out of everything you
did I think you're in a great position
to give advice to uh like new dancers
coming to town because I feel like in
your first years you did exactly what
everyone was too afraid to do yeah
everyone's too scared to like meet the
amount of people you met and do the
amount of work you did like it was it
that's the fastest and most I've seen
anybody like do everything at once yeah
yeah you really I think a part of it too
like I always give advice to people that
are moving out here especially dancers
is like finding people that are the best
at what they do and just learning from
them like offering even like free work
and just surrounding yourself by that
because you learn so quick from it and
also [ __ ] the regular path like I think
that's what Philip helped me and you
guys help me because there is this
structured out dancer path you know you
move to LA you get your agent you go to
the auditions self tapes that was not me
at all and it's like doing what you want
to do and kind of like creating your own
path into becoming like whatever you
want to be is that a cookie cutter
[Music]